اظهرت مقاطع فيديو انتشرت بكثافه على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لحظات الدار
والرعب اثناء الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب
تركيا صباح اليوم الاثنين
[موسيقى]
وضرب زلزال بلغت قوته 7.9 درجه جنوب تركيه
في ساعه مبكره من الصباح وشعر بها سكان
قبرص ولبنان وسوريا والعراق ومصر ما ادى
الى انهيار مباني وخروج السكان الى شوارع
المغطاه بالثلوج
[موسيقى]
وقد ادى الزلزال العنيف الى سقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرحى وحصار العشرات تحت انقاذ
المباني المهدمه
[موسيقى]
فقد اعلنت السلطات التركيه درجه الانذار
الرابعه التي تعني طلب مساعده دوليه
ويساهم الجيش التركي في نقل الفرق الطبيه
الى المناطق المنكوبه
وقال المركز الالماني لابحاث علوم الارض
ان الزلزال وقع على عمق عشره كيلو مترات
بالقرب من مدينه كرهان مرعش بجنوب تركيا
[موسيقى]
بينما قال المركز الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد
الزلزال انه يجري تقييمه احتمالي حدوث
موجات مدن عملاقه تسونامي
وقال شاهد من رويترز في ديار بكر الواقعه
على بعد 350 كيلو مترا الى الشرق ان
الزلزال استمر نحو دقيقه وخطم النوافذ
[موسيقى]